[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous chapter we had been
talking about the calculus of variations
and i had mentioned a number of things
which
the calculus of variations will enable
us to do in this
entire course of advanced mechanics of
solids especially pertaining to the
cases of
beams and plates now the way that we had
proceeded in
discussing the few things in calculus of
variations was
quite abstract and mathematical and uh
you may be wondering and rightly so that
how could we
possibly connect it to things which are
very much tangible
and mechanical like beams and plates so
the
uh so what we are beginning i'm going to
discuss from today
uh is a new chapter called energy
methods and it is through this chapter
that the connection will be established
between the mathematics that we
discussed in the calculus of variations
and the rest of this course so this
current chapter is an
extremely extremely important chapter
acting as a bridge
between the maps and the actual
mechanical objects
all right so without any further ado let
us go into some of the preliminary
discussions
and again you will see that in the
preliminary discussions
there will be a few things which may
look a bit uh
mathematically abstract uh but as i said
uh we are going to establish a bridge
between the maths
and the real mechanical things so uh
as you can imagine so the first uh
one side of the bridge has the
connection with the mats so that's uh
that's how we start off
all right
so here are some preliminary concepts uh
the first concept has to do with the
configuration so we are going to define
a few things here
uh the
configuration uh it is defined as the
positions
of all the material points of a
mechanical system
so all the all these positions together
they are referred to
as the configuration of the system so
written in this fashion uh it may not
make too much sense
unless you have a certain mathematical
flavor in your brain
uh so uh let's see if you can if i can
if i can uh concretize the ideas a
little bit
so let me just switch on the video
again uh and let's discuss this
configuration
definition the positions of all the
material points of the mechanical system
are together referred to as the
configuration of the system so what do
we mean by that really
okay so let us take the uh the example
of a very simple mechanical system uh
which is
my hand okay so my hand is like this
here
so what we are going to say is that this
is one particular configuration of my
hand
as it is okay so what i mean by my hand
is that this this part
this entire thing okay forget my face
and everything else
in this camera okay so
uh this is one configuration
you can understand that if i change
the position of my thumb like this that
is another configuration
if i put change the position of my thumb
like this
that is another configuration if i
position
my fingers like this then that is
another configuration
furthermore if i just keep it like this
and
change it like this change it like that
okay so all of them all of these things
the various
uh configurations literally okay
so constituting the fact that
in these different positions the
material points which make up my hand
the various material points which make
up my hand
all these points okay including those in
my thumb my index finger everything here
so as they are occupying different
different positions
each of these things is
one configuration okay so
uh so
just just uh just a second let me get
come back to this thing
uh you think about uh
another possibility where my
thumb you imagine that this part of my
thumb
is touching here now some people can do
that
but i cannot without breaking this joint
here
so a question is
whether that would be considered part of
this mechanical system okay or or
whether that that configuration would be
an acceptable one
now if you allow for the fact that this
mechanical system of my hand
is allowed to be broken at this joint
then certainly
that configuration is also an acceptable
one
okay otherwise not okay so this little
discussion that we had at the end
that will have some consequences in the
in our future discussions also
please remember that okay so
uh let me get back to the definitions
continuing
next we have configuration space so
uh just as i had told you that
one particular mechanical system can
have very many different configurations
so the configuration space
is basically uh just the set of all the
very many different configurations that
can be taken by the mechanical system
okay that's what it is okay so not much
to discuss here uh
next this is where it becomes a little
bit abstract mathematically
the geometric notation okay so
uh so let me just discuss this
so any point in the configuration space
of a mechanical system is denoted by
x now please do not get confused by this
notation x
which back in applied elasticity we had
used to refer to
the position of a particular material
point
this x does not refer to the position
vector of a particular material point no
it refers this x it subsumes within
it the entire representation of the
configuration
so for example if i switch back my video
here
if i hold my hand like this the entire
representation of
all the material points okay that entire
representation
all the material points that would just
be represented by this
by that variable x if i change it that
will be another x
okay so uh so it is not
pertaining to any one particular
material point here here here also it is
constituting everything
okay
all right so in order to understand this
one may think of the simplest of
mechanical systems which is just
one particle then of course we can say
that because in that particle there is
only one material point
then x can be the position vector of the
particle
but if it is constituting of a
fairly complicated system like my hand
then x
is certainly not the position vector is
not mind you again i emphasize this
x is not the position vector of any one
point
on my hand x is the entire
representation
of all the material points that is
present in one particular configuration
okay next to continue
uh
we have another concept which is uh
the distance in configuration space
okay so what is this so when a
mechanical system goes
from one configuration uh say
we represented by uh the variable x
naught
in configuration space to another
configuration say x1 in configuration
space
then the distance between x naught and
x1 is defined to be the maximum of the
displacement magnitudes
of the individual particles making up
the system so what what we mean by that
okay so let me again switch on the video
here
so here again this is one particular
configuration of my hand
this is represented by let's say x
naught
now this is another configuration of my
hand
let's say this is x one now
uh i wish i could show you on the camera
two
two different copies of my right hand
but i can't do that so you just use your
imagination a little bit
now uh all that i'm changing is the
position of my thumb like this
so this is x naught and this is x one
okay
and i'm talking about my entire hand now
so
what we'll say is that uh the distance
between this
x naught this entire configuration x
naught
and this configuration which is x one
that will be defined
by the maximum of the displacement
magnitudes
of all the material points considered so
if you for example if you consider the
this thing the material point at the tip
of my little finger
then that is not changing at all between
x naught and x one
so that that is zero that difference is
zero
okay so the displacement there is zero
suppose you consider the material point
which is at the middle point of my
thumb so it is going from here to here
because x naught here
this is x one so if you consider
the displacement magnitude of the middle
part of my thumb
that will have a certain value but the
displacement magnitude of
the tip of my thumb between x naught and
x one
will have a higher value as you can
understand from this configuration
okay so of all this of all the different
uh displacement magnitudes
that are possible between two different
configurations the one that has the
maximum value that will be referred to
as the distance between
x naught and x one okay so this is a
very subtle thing to
understand i hope there is no such there
is no confusion
the next point uh is even more subtle
okay and i deliberately did not write it
earlier i want to write i mean discuss
it as we go along
okay so this is a path in configuration
space
okay so
the path in configuration space what do
we mean by that
well uh
you think of it like this first of all
we say
that the configuration
of a mechanical system the configuration
x okay the configuration x of a
mechanical system so i will not write
too many words here
rather i'll just describe it all the
words the formal words that are present
that will be present in the lecture
notes uh you can go through them
at your leisure later on
let me just first discuss the concept
okay so we consider this
x representing the but a particular
configuration
of a mechanical system and we say that
this x
is a function of some
variable t bar
okay this is some scalar variable t bar
please note that right away you don't
you don't
think that this t bar is necessarily
time it could be it could not be we'll
discuss that
a little bit later for now you just
think that this configuration
x it it it is a
function of some scalar variable t bar
and let's say that
this t bar is such that it is a line
between
two things okay so this is just a way to
represent
completely in a mathematical fashion so
we say that this x is a function
of t bar if to each point
t bar that is lying between a and b if
we have
a a particular value of x
okay so i repeat so if to each value t
bar lying between a and b
we have a value of x then we say that x
is a
function of e bar now
the the function
of performed uh what we'll say is that
this uh so as you can understand so as
we keep on changing t bar this x will
also change
and every time this x changes it will
represent
a different configuration in
configuration space going by all our
discussions earlier
now uh this function so formed
it what we'll say is that it represents
a path in configuration space
okay so this function
it represents
a path
in configuration space
but please do not jump to conclusions
just from the moment you see the word
path
okay we have to qualify this up properly
so this function represents a path in
configuration space
but very importantly we have to note
that every path that we may think of
okay every path uh
may not be admissible okay it may not be
allowed
and we'll discuss this properly okay so
every part may not be
admissible because
of the constraints present in the
mechanical system so because of the
constraints
we must always always have to we always
have to respect the constraints of the
mechanical system
and because those constraints may be
present not every path that you may
think of
may be admissible okay so what do we
mean by that
so for that let me see if i can
if i can give you some sort of a
concrete example
so again let me switch on the video
okay so this time we'll consider
slightly more complicated situation
we will consider my hand like this my
right hand like this
and i will also consider my left hand
but before doing that
i will place a bottle cap in my right
hand
okay and my left hand is like this
so this is an artificially contrived
example but i hope it will
help you to clarify the ideas so
uh you understand that my right hand
my left hand and the bottle cap which is
present
here this one this bottle gap this
together can
constitute the mechanical system okay
all these things the right hand the left
hand
and the bottle cap together they are
referred they are our
mechanical system of interest and you
also understand
that gravity is very much acting you
forget my face my
sweater and all this background and
everything just just
think of this thing and the constraint
okay the constraint that we impose on
this thing
is that all of this this right hand is
left hand and the bottle gap
it must be present
within the field view of this camera i
told you this is an artificially
contract example but this is this is how
we
we choose our mechanical system so it
must be always present
in the field view of this camera so this
is not acceptable
okay because my right hand has now gone
away from the field view of the camera
okay so i always have to maintain it
like this okay
now let us say that we want to consider
different different configurations
of this mechanical system that we have
chosen
okay so another configuration that could
be possible
is that this bottle gap goes from my
right hand
to my left hand like this
okay just a simple transfer so this is
another
configuration of the mechanical system
that i have chosen
now you see what i have done in the
process let me repeat it
i was holding it like this i hope i held
it like this
so this intermediate positions
of my hands this also represents
a configuration of our mechanical system
okay you think about it very carefully
now i'm moving my hands slowly so each
of these
each of these little little uh each of
these
uh little increments that i'm i'm
showing you
they all of these intermediate
configurations
they are very much configurations of the
mechanical system and they're all
respecting the constraints that we have
imposed that all throughout this thing
starting from here to here all these
intermediate positions
i'm respecting the constraints of my
mechanical system which is that
everything should be present in the
field view of the camera and i'm slowly
uh putting it in my left hand and i am
bringing my hand back here
okay so
all the things all the all the
configurations
okay all the configurations that have
taken place in this
transfer they together constitute
a path it's a path because we have
respected the
constraints of the system but suppose
let us go back to the initial
configuration
like this and suppose what i do is i
just
i just leave my thumb like this and let
it fall
so i don't want to make it dirty okay so
i'll just drop it like this
imagine that i have dropped it now you
see
some problem has happened because i left
my thumb like that and let it drop
okay i did not actually show you the
dropping because i didn't want it to
fall on the floor
i just kept it in my on my chair here
but
uh what has happened is that
gravity has very much acted uh on this
thing
and the gap is now
down below now
if i say that i want to have the bottle
cap transferred to my left hand
okay that is problematic because
in order to achieve that i have to
move either of my hands away from the
field view of the camera
but that is not respecting the
constraints of the system
which is that everything should be
present within the
within the field view of the camera in
fact i have already violated
so the the moment after i i let go of
the bottle cap
i've already violated the constraints of
the system which is that
the bottle cap very much was part of my
mechanical system
and that has now also disappeared from
the field view of the camera
so this intermediate position like the
bottle cap is lying on my chair
okay uh in my lap and
although these two hands are there in
the field of the camera
but the bottle cap is not so it is this
intermediate configuration so to speak
uh is not an admissible configuration
okay this particular configuration with
the bottle cap lying in my lap
away from the field view of the camera
and even though these two hands may be
present in the field of the camera
this is not an admissible configuration
because you have already violated the
constraints of the system okay so even
if
i now claim that no okay no problem i'll
just pick
it up and put it in my left hand okay so
you think you see under
uh you see what has happened i let go of
this bottle cap it fell
here and then i just came down here
put it back in my left hand but if you
claim
that this entire motion this thing
falling down
and then my hand going away from the
field view of the camera picking it up
and putting it back here
that is a part of the of the of the
mechanical system
then that is untrue that is false
that is not an acceptable that's not an
admissible path
i mean you can't say that there is a
path but it is not an admissible path
because it is violating the
constraints of the system so i hope with
this little example
some ideas will be concretized in your
brain
okay so uh one very very important
notion before i
end this video is that uh
this variable t that we were talking
about it's uh it's quite an abstract
thing
uh so uh and and you will understand why
we have to write it like this t but in
in the in the next part of the in our
next video
uh for now you just note that this
variable t bar this
variable t bar
is not necessarily the time
if if it is
indeed the time
if it is indeed the time
then
the then this function
x of t bar where t bar is equal to t
the time is
uh called the motion of the system okay
so such a special
path it is called
the motion of the system
okay so the motion of the system is a
special case of the path
when this scalar variable t bar happens
to be the time
okay so that is something we are all
familiar with when we say we
uh that's okay so one one mechanical
system is going
from one point to another point through
a certain path what we really
would really mean uh in these terms is
that
we are we are describing the motion of
the system okay
so this difference between the t bar and
the t that will become
more evident clear in the next
video where we are going to discuss
about virtual displacements
all right with this i end this video
thank you very much